[موسيقى
] لقد وصلت إلى جنة جزر المالديف
[موسيقى] لقد
استمر الوباء لأكثر من
عام والحقيقة
أعتقد أننا كنا نأمل الآن في أن تكون الأمور
أكثر انفتاحًا عندما يكون الواقع مثل
موجة أخرى
لا تزال موجودة  الكثير من قيود السفر
مع وضع ذلك في الاعتبار هذا الشهر ، لقد جئت
إلى جزر المالديف
لأنه بدلاً من الذهاب إلى ثقافة
واحدة في بلد
واحد ، أتيت إلى بلد
من اثنتي عشرة جزيرة حيث كل
جزيرة هي نفسها عالم من العجائب
[موسيقى
] ولذا يجب أن أبدأ في
البداية أول منتجع هنا في جزر
المالديف ، الجزيرة عبارة عن فقاعة مغطاة قليلاً
تم اختبار الجميع على الجزيرة
وهي سلبية ،
لذا فإن السياسة هنا هي أنك لست بحاجة إلى
ارتداء قناع
ولكن  أعتقد أن صديقنا القديم الكثير
من الحذر يأتي دورًا ،
سأحتفظ به حيث أكون حول
أشخاص آخرين ، المياه الفيروزية المضيئة الشهيرة
توفر الحماية والهدوء التي
سعى إليها البحارة منذ
قرون كما هو الحال بالنسبة للسياح الحديثين.
لم يحضروا هنا
حتى عام 1972.
هذا هو المكان الذي جاء فيه الأشخاص بالضبط إلى
المكان الذي اعتدنا فيه أن
نقيم حفل الشواء هذا هنا
، ثم اعتدنا أن يكون لدينا شخص
تعرفه يعزف على الجيتار في نار
هذا هو الرجل الذي بنى  الجنة
هذا ما يقولونه عن محمد أوما
مانيكو
أو مو لفترة قصيرة منذ ما يقرب من 50 عامًا
، كان أحد الرواد الذين اختاروا
هذه
الجزيرة وأنشأ كارومبا لقضاء العطلات الإيطاليين
الباحثين عن صيد غير ملوث ، ولم يكن هناك
شيء هنا ،
كان هناك شخصان تعرفهما من
حراس الجزيرة هنا
و  كانت هذه مجرد جزيرة ، وكان
التحدي الأكبر
لأنه لم يكن لديك شيء هنا كنت
قادرًا على بنائه ، وقبل فترة طويلة
تم افتتاح منتجعات أخرى بسرعة كبيرة ، نعم
كان التحدي الأكبر
هو الحصول على الإمدادات هنا ،
وقد تم بناؤه باستخدام المرجان المكسور
والمرجاني.  أنت تعرف الجير في البدايات كانت
أماكن الإقامة خالية ،
لذا كان على الحد الأدنى من الزوار أن يخوضوا من
القارب
عبر الأمواج للوصول إلى الشاطئ في تلك
المنازل الأولى  لقد بنيت ، نعم ، كان لديهم
مراحيض غريبة بالمياه معتدلة الملوحة ،
نعم لم تكن تعرف حقًا ما
كنت تفعله فيما يتعلق بتجربة
السياحة ، حيث كانوا سعداء للغاية لأنهم
سعداء جدًا جدًا ، وقد علم بعضهم
أن سرير التشمس رائع جدًا.
مثل الكركند ،
نحن متحمسون جدًا لأنني تعلم
أنه كان بإمكاني أن أخبرك أنه كان هناك
الكثير من
الأنا وأعني أن النار بداخلي ذهبنا
ولم ننظر إلى الوراء أبدًا ، هل شككت في أنه
سيكون
نجاحًا لم أشك في ذلك أبدًا  أنه
من بدايات كارامبا المتواضعة التي سينموها الآخرون ،
هناك أكثر من مائة منتجع
منتشرة
عبر مختلف الجزر اليوم
مو سعيد للسماح لأطفاله
بتولي إدارة الأعمال
التي لا تزال هناك  الروح
لا تزال موجودة
إذا لم أتمكن من المجيء إلى هنا في يوم واحد
ثم أتجول هنا
، يبدو الأمر وكأن شيئًا ما مفقودًا في حياتي ،
كما تعلم ،
أعتقد أن هذا ما يبحث عنه الناس ،
أنت تعرف
الطبيعة كما هي ، أعني أنها مجرد
شيء  نعم الجنة ثم زوجتي
السابقة
لقد بدأ السبي لك للتو